well I hope you had a great weekend I
know that I did because I am emotionally
dysfunctional and codependent and that
means that my mood is determined by the
fate of my favorite football team which
is which is really strange when you
think about it and and and kind of sad
and pathetic but the Ravens dominated
yet again yesterday so I'm feeling
pretty good
in fact I'm feeling even better because
I get to spend the first part of this
show discussing a football related topic
which I always enjoy and that's the one
thing that I will thank Colin Kaepernick
for is that he he gives me an excuse
every once in a while to talk about
football in the show so I do like that
yes Kaepernick over the weekend exposed
who he has been all along who I think he
has plainly been all along which is that
he is a con man he's not interested in
in playing football he's interested in
PR stunts this shouldn't be news to
anyone but I think maybe it is and so
we'll get into that we'll talk about it
along with several other topics
including speaking of people being
exposed Prince Andrew was interviewed by
the BBC in regards to rape allegations
against him and in regards to his
relationship with Jeffrey Epstein
Jeffrey Epstein who by the way didn't
kill himself and Prince Andrew offers
what I honestly think is the worst alibi
I have ever heard in my life and I'm not
exaggerating it's not hyperbole I think
it really is the worst alibi anyone has
ever given for anything and we'll talk
about that along with a number of other
important topics as well but first a
word from quit you know quip makers of
the equip electric toothbrush want you
to know that the one single discovery
that matters the most for your dental
care is simply this that if you have
good habits you're good it's basic and
simple as that and that means brushing
for two minutes twice a day flossing
regularly no matter what brand you use
quit makes that simple starting with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
anti cavity toothpaste equips electric
brush has sensitive sonic vibrations
with a built-in timer and 30-second
pulses to guide and full to guide you
through a full and even clean so it's
you know it's like going to the dentist
except you don't have to actually go to
the dentist that's the best part about
the quit floss dispenser comes with pre
marked string to help you use just
enough plus quip delivers fresh brush
head floss and toothpaste refills to
your door every three months with free
shipping and so this is all about
getting you into that routine keeping
you in the routine and making sure that
it's always right join over 3 million
healthy mouth healthy mouths and get
quit today
starting at $25 and if you go to get
quick comm slash Walsh right now you'll
get your first refill for free that's
your first refill free yet get qyp
dot-com slash Walsh spelled GE T Q u IP
comm slash Walsh quit the good habits
company ok Colin Kapernick the former
mediocre NFL quarterback who
coincidentally discovered a passion for
social justice once his star had faded
already after an abysmal 2015 campaign
with the 49ers when he lost five six of
the eight games that he started and
posted only six touchdowns against five
interceptions that Colin Kaepernick was
scheduled to work out for 25 teams this
past Saturday and I think the
circumstances of this workout are
unusual and worth worth reflecting on
here for a moment Kaepernick of course
has been out of the league since 2016
that's the same year that he began his
infamous anthem protest but I think more
salience to his three years of
unemployment is the fact that not that
he had the anthem protests in 2016 but
that he went 1 in 10 that season posting
only about 2000 2241 yards passing 16
touchdowns before getting benched for
blaine gabbert and if you don't follow
football let me just tell you that
getting benched for blaine gabbert
is the NFL equivalent of your dance
troupe replacing you with Sean Spicer it
really doesn't get any more humiliating
than that
Kaepernick though as he's been
unemployed has done pretty well for
himself during his period of jobless and
that's better than most people do when
they're out of work for three years
signed a multi-million dollar ad deal
with Nike and he's been hailed across
the media as a civil rights Marv
so not a bad side gig while you're out
of work but the point here is that he'd
fallen out of his short-lived prime well
before his anthem antics starting and
and you might even say that that's not a
coincidence that in fact that's the
reason why he started with the anthem
antics then and not before
so he's fallen out of his prime and then
he spends three years shooting Nike ads
instead of playing football now I'm not
aware of any other case and I'm not
saying it's never happened I'm just not
aware of any other case it's certainly
unusual for the NFL to hold a private
midseason workout on a Saturday no less
the day before game day okay teams were
getting ready last-minute preparations
for Sunday for football Sunday so this
is on a Saturday in week 11 of the
season I'm not aware of a workout like
this private midseason attended by 25
Scouts for a backup level talent who's
been out of the league for 35 months yet
that's what Kaepernick demanded and
that's what he got there is no
conceivable football reason for the NFL
to have gone to these lengths for Colin
Kaepernick he's not a star player he
never was a star player he looked like
he was threatening to maybe be a star
player in that what was 2012 season
where he went to the Super Bowl and lost
by the way to Joe Flacco which is
another humiliation so this is a guy who
lost to Joe Flacco in the Super Bowl and
then a few years later was benched for
Blaine Gabbert it really is as annoyed
as I am with Cabernet at the same time I
think well this is a man who suffered
two of the worst humiliations that any
person could ever possibly endure but
anyway not a star player never was a
star player even but even if he was a
star player it would still be highly
unusual and probably unprecedented for
the league to stage an event of this
sort just for him in the middle of the
season
but it still wasn't good enough for
Kaepernick and it actually because I'm
thinking about it what could possibly be
analogous to this well you think about
maybe you know Michael Vick was a star
play Michael Vick was a transcendent
athlete one of the prime all-star
players of the of the of his decade you
know the the early two-thousands
obviously left the league because he
went to prison for dogfighting
came back two years later after two
years out of the league and he did he
came back and he had one all-pro season
with the with the Eagles which was
really impressive but anyway I I don't
think that the NFL it has to go back and
look at pretty sure the NFL didn't do
this for Michael Vick what they did for
Kaepernick they didn't do for Vick I'm
pretty sure and Vick was by far a bigger
star than Kaepernick ever was but this
was as I said not good enough for
Kaepernick and and so the Nike salesman
pulled out at the last minute
apparently deciding that sometime on
Saturday morning that he needed to have
the event open to the media the NFL
didn't want the event open to the media
they never agreed to that and four
perfectly understandable reasons they
weren't looking to have a Kaepernick
Appaloosa media spectacle in week 11 of
the of the regular season they were they
weren't looking to play host to a
televised PR stunt for an out-of-work 32
year old former bench writer why would
they want to do that what how could you
possibly expect them to
they've already enlisted I'll I'm no
defender of the NFL as an organization
even though I enjoy the the product on
the field with some exceptions but
on this how could you blame them of
course they don't want media there what
why would they want the media there and
I think any sane a reasonable person
couldn't possibly expect them to but
Kaepernick is plenty sane but he's not
reasonable or at least his reasons are
entirely separate from the reasons of a
real athlete who really wants to play
football which Colin Kaepernick does not
so the guy who wore pig socks mocking
the police during a game back in 2016
cancelled the or rather pulled out of
the league hosted event at the last
minute staged his own event instead
complete with News cameras and
journalists of course a lot of
journalists there who don't follow
football and so they came and they
watched Colin Kaepernick throw the
football 50 yards in the air to an
uncovered wide receiver running down you
know doing a just-just-just running up a
straight right route down down the down
the sideline and a bunch of non-sports
journalists see that and start talking
about wow he looked great out there this
guy needs to be on a team stat yeah just
because you can do that doesn't mean
that you're gonna be a good quarterback
in the NFL a lot of people can do that
see when you're when you're really
evaluating you're looking at things like
footwork you know his accuracy and
timing explosiveness his vision on the
field and those sorts of things which
are hard to evaluate and it'll work out
the way that this one was conducted but
in all of those areas
he's never been very good and he's
certainly gonna be worse now than he was
back when he was playing three years ago
Kaepernick also made another conspicuous
wardrobe decision
sporting a kunta kinte shirt implicitly
comparing himself with a slave now I
admit that I'm no history professor okay
but I'm pretty sure that the plight of a
multi-millionaire who had to settle for
Hawking Nike shoes because he couldn't
get a job in the NFL
he bears no resemblance to historical
slavery and then as if the whole
look-at-me nature of the thing wasn't
clear enough Kapernick then went and
entities on the scene about how the 32
teams and roger goodell are running from
the truth and running from the new
people in fact watch watch his rant at
the end of his workout look at this are
you doing for the people and telling the
truth that's what we want everything
I'll be ready for three years I've been
denied for three years we all know why I
came out here showed it today in front
of everybody
we have nothing to hide so we're waiting
for the 32 owners 32 teams Roger Goodell
all of them to stop running stop running
from the truth
stop running from the people around here
we're ready to play we're ready to go
anywhere my agent Jeff nalli is ready to
talk to any team I interview any team at
any time I've been ready
I'm staying ready and I'll continue to
be ready and so all the people that came
out here today to support I appreciate
y'all I love y'all too the people that
are here I'm thinking of you I
appreciate you supporting from where you
are we'll continue to give you updates
as we hear we'll be waiting to hear from
Roger Goodell the NFL the 32 teams we'll
let you know if we hear from them balls
in their court we're ready to go now I
have been on my share of job interviews
in my life as as have many people I've
never considered canceling the interview
at the last minute changing venues
demanding that my my prospective
employer come to me rather than me to
him and then accusing him of running
from the truth when he fails to
immediately hire me now that's that's an
interesting strategy maybe my next job
interview I'll try it you know finish
the interview I come in dressed in a
purposely inflammatory attire and then
at the end of the interview I say so so
do I have the job well well well we'll
call you we'll get back to you stop
running from the truth I know what
you're doing you're running from the
truth and from the people
but people want me to have this job now
give it to me um I don't know maybe I'll
maybe I'll give that a try we'll see it
does seem very much like the strategy of
a man who doesn't actually want the job
that he's pretending to seek consider
how this whole thing might have gone if
Kaepernick did want to play football
well he would have scheduled his workout
in the offseason first of all when a
number of teams are still making roster
decisions deciding who the quarterbacks
going to be and they would have had
timed if they did all from a contract to
integrate him into the offense he could
learn the playbook and everything and
then he would have shown up to the venue
in a spirit of gratitude and eagerness
he would not have worn a t-shirt
advertising his martyr complex he would
not have scolded the NFL in front of
news cameras he would not have insisted
on news cameras in the first place
because it's not they're not the people
are gonna be hiring him he's not he's
not he's trying out to be a football
quarterback not to be a Cable News
talking head but if there were cameras
there and he did talk to them his
post-workout comments would have focused
on imagine this football and he would
have expressed a deep desire to make a
roster and help a team win games and he
would have said stuff like that I just
want to help a team win games is it that
kind of thing that those are the sort of
things you say when you want to be on a
football team Kaepernick said none of
that because he's not interested in
playing football he is a self-promoting
fraud and this is his very profitable I
must admit
con this is a con he's a con man on a
pragmatic level you know it's hard to
argue with his logic if you put the
ethics and the morality and honesty and
all that aside you're not worried about
that it makes sense because with his
diminished skill set his advanced age at
least by football standards he's 32 okay
he could at best hope to be a kind of
journey man second-stringer hopping from
one roster to the other waiting for a
starter to go down so we can fill in for
a few games
um he kind of like Robert Griffin the
third right now rg3 that's what he's
doing now RG three is his three years
younger than Kaepernick and was once
more promising than Kaepernick was but
now he earns a couple million dollars a
year playing behind Lamar Jackson he's
kind of Lamar Jackson's mentor and
backup and he's good in that role
because he's got in control of his ego
and he's trying to help the team win and
he's and he's now whereas before there
may have been issues with this but now
he's kind of humble and and and he's not
trying to make make it all about him and
it's it's a nice way to make a living
look if I could make a living if I could
get paid two million dollars a year to
be a backup quarterback in the NFL I
would do it but it's not as rich or
glamorous of a life as the life of a not
Nike sponsored professional Martin
Kaepernick has carved out that niche for
himself the professional martyr Nike
sponsor he got a Nike sponsorship but as
a professional martyr no one's ever done
that before and that is better for him I
guess he's decided that he'd rather do
that then accept the comparatively
humble existence of a comparatively low
paid benchwarmer in the NFL and that's
why cap and his team of PR reps have
made sure to stay in that zone between
trying for a job in the NFL and actually
landing a job in the NFL they don't want
it they don't want to cross over into
landing a job so they just stay in that
zone and they've discovered that that
zone is filled with money and clout now
with all this in mind it would be
incredibly stupid and counterproductive
for any team to offer
Kaepernick a contract of course you
can't put it past an organization like
the Bengals or the Jets to do an
incredibly stupid and counterproductive
thing that's all they do after all but
nonetheless he is a washed-up second
string quarterback who in the very best
case scenario if he's able to reach the
meager Heights from which he fell in
2016 may
we could get you 2,000 yards and you
know a dozen or so touchdowns at best
now most backups in the league can get
you that or better and the thing is none
of them are gonna bring the media circus
along with them none of them will
threaten to turn your fan base against
you none of them have the potential rip
your locker room into pieces the way the
Kaepernick does and none of them are
likely to call you a racist
if you have to cut them which eventually
you will all bag of quarterbacks
basically inevitably get cut or retire
so Kaepernick's production even in the
best case possible scenario could not
possibly come close to compensating for
the massive downside I'm not sure that
even Tom Brady and his prime could
compensate for a downside as steep as
caps and Kaepernick is no Tom Brady to
say the least this is this is not
everyone talking about it's a conspiracy
by the league they don't want capper
it's not a conspiracy this is very
simple if you're an NFL owner why in
god's name would you ever hire this guy
he's given everything I just mentioned
the very high likelihood fanbase turns
against you locker room is ripped in
half because some of the players are
gonna love him some are gonna hate him
he makes it all about himself he's very
me focused he's not a team player and he
wasn't a team player even back when he
was on in the league and and you just
you just absolutely know that if you cut
him or if you know if you don't if if
you bench him when he thinks he should
be playing he's gonna start accusing you
of races and all the stuff why would you
ever bring that on yourself he's not
good enough for that and even I mean
some would take someone like Tim Tebow
Tim Tebow is not a narcissist or a fraud
the way the Cabernet is but Tim Tebow
bit washed out of the NFL and couldn't
get a job after he he let left the
Broncos and was on the Jets for a little
bit and I figured a stint on the on the
Patriots
and that was it and the reason is now he
has the talent to be a backup
quarterback he doesn't have first-string
talent but he has second-string talent
for sure um but he's got he's had this
whole media circus that follows him
around and that's not his fault he
didn't intentionally cultivate that
circus the way the kaepernick does but
nonetheless he has it and so teams are
saying I you know I don't want this for
a backup this isn't what you want in a
backup and you bring Tebow in and you're
gonna have all you know now all the
sudden half of the fans are gonna be
chanting for him to go on the field even
if you know even if the starting
quarterback is better than him is that
why would we want this we don't want it
maybe though as I think about it you
know a contract offer from the bangles
from a team like the bangles would would
be the most poetic result in all of this
after all of his maneuvering to avoid an
offer because like I said he doesn't
want one it's not what this is about but
it would be pretty delicious to see him
backed into a corner where he has to
actually reject an offer because one his
one is made to him thereby revealing the
whole charade for what it is or he has
to admit defeat and actually accept a
fate worse than death which is to be a
Bengals quarterback as far as I see it
either of those options would be the
most fitting and deserved end to the
Colin Kaepernick saga but I guess we'll
see what happens okay uh moving on
Prince Andrew he was a good friend of
the now dead pedophile and sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein who of course
did not kill himself he hung out with
Epstein a lot stayed at his house went
on trips with him and so forth now he's
also been accused prince andrew has by
name specifically of raping at least one
woman and that accusation comes from the
woman herself Virginia Roberts she says
that she was recruited as a child a
minor was trafficked all around the
world we know that this is exactly the
kind of thing a Cabernet
that's that Epstein does it's exactly
the kind of thing that apps team does
and so this is the accusation that she
made against Epstein and and Prince
Andrew and he was interviewed by the BBC
now the the way the BBC interview phrase
is this is that he was accused of having
sex with Bridget Roberts but that's
that's not the right term here the
proper term is rape he was accused of
raping Virginia Roberts who was a minor
and was sex trafficked okay and she was
raped she says by many men but Prince
Andrew was was one of them and this
happened she says three times now Prince
Angier was finally interviewed by the
BBC and it really is a sight to behold
and to hear I don't think I've ever seen
a denial that so clearly seems to
confirm the accusation what I mean is
I've never seen anyone deny something
and look and sound so guilty as they
deny it it really is incredible so first
here's Prince Andrew explaining that he
hung out with a pedophile because of his
great sense of honour listen to this one
of Epstein's accusers Virginia Roberts
has made allegations against you
she says she met you in 2001 she says
she dined with you danced with you at
[ __ ] nightclub in London she went on to
have sex with you in a house in
Belgravia belonging to girl and Maxwell
your friend your response I have no
recollection of ever meeting this lady
you don't remember meeting have it but
you were staying at the house it was
convicted sex offender it was a
convenient place to stay there's I mean
I mean I've gone through this in my mind
so many times at the end of the day with
the benefit of all the hindsight that
one could have it was definitely
the wrong thing to do but at the time I
felt it was it was the honorable and
right thing to do
and I admit fully that that my judgment
was probably colored by my tendency to
be too honorable but that's just the way
it did yes he he stayed with a convicted
pedophile at a convicted paedophiles
house because he's too honorable I mean
this would be a terrible answer in a job
interview when you know when they ask
you what are your weaknesses your
greatest weakness that question now my
answer to that used to be the classic of
well I work too hard
you know sometimes I forget to stop and
smell the roses just such a hard worker
I I'm just so focused sometimes I'm just
so focused I do such a great job my you
know I do such a great job I'm so
dedicated that that you know I tend to
enjoy life a little bit less that I
would otherwise that is typically been
my answer everyone has a bad answer to
that question this one would be really
bad even by those standards and except
it's a lot worse because this isn't a
job interview this is an interview with
the BBC about rape accusations and this
is what he comes up with and it gets
worse if you could believe it watch this
so you're absolutely sure that you're at
home on the 10th of March she was very
specific about that night she described
Dancing with you and you profusely
sweating and that she went on to have
possibly there's a slight problem with
with with with with the sweating because
I have a peculiar medical condition
which is that I don't sweat or I didn't
sweat at the time and that was machine
yes
I didn't sweat at the time because I had
suffered what I would describe as an
overdose of adrenaline in the Falklands
War when I was shot at and I simply it
was it was it was almost impossible for
me to sweat and it's only because I have
done a number
things in the recent past but I'm
starting to be able to do that again so
I'm afraid to say that there's a medical
condition that says that it didn't do it
so therefore yeah he remembers listen he
remembers not sweating he remembers not
sweating he remembers that at the time
when this didn't happen
he didn't sweat he remembers not
sweating as the thing did not occur you
see it was a medical condition so we can
look at his camp his calendar and say oh
no what day was that was that the 16th
of April let me check my yet no it says
we're here I didn't sweat that day yeah
that was a non sweating day yeah it's my
I got my sweat schedule right here my my
you know my sweat shoul I call it and I
keep track of all the days sighs right
now I did sweat the day before on the
the day before between 3:00 p.m. and
5:00 p.m. I did a little bit of sweating
picked up some sweating about 8:00 p.m.
to 8:30 but then I didn't sweat again
for another three and a half days this
is what he's trying to say it is I mean
it's stunning and this is the kind of
excuse that someone like Prince Andrew
can make now that's not going to work
for a everyday peasant like me or you if
we went with the I know I didn't do it
because I didn't sweat if the brow
doesn't drip you must acquit if you were
I tried to go with that it's not going
to work but Prince Andrew yeah he can
say that his excuses are I hung out with
a pedophile because I'm just too
honorable I'm such an honorable guy and
you know that I didn't do this thing I'm
accused of because I also don't sweat I
am a an honorable non sweaty person this
is what you get now why does the royal
family exist this is why a gaggle of
crooks and leeches their only job
to be rich and live in a fancy house
what's the point
and why do Americans love these people
I've never understood that we fought a
war to be rid of them and now we buy
tabloid magazines oh says here that
Prince Harry has athlete's foot wow did
you see this I don't get it
and listen I understand tradition when I
talk about this people are sad it's
tradition it's joy aren't you a
traditionalist don't you believe in
tradition yeah I believe in tradition I
think it's great to preserve tradition
but I think there are two mistakes that
that people often make with respect to
tradition one is to assume that
something is bad and archaic and
backwards and and and barbaric and
primitive just because it's a tradition
and so to try to overturn traditions
simply because they are traditions so
that's a big mistake that people make in
this culture especially and I'm totally
against that but then only on the other
end of that extreme there's the mistake
of thinking that everything that is a
tradition should just be preserved
simply because it's a tradition even if
it no longer serves the purpose it once
served even if it's now extremely
counterproductive even if it's you know
even if it's sort of devoid of all the
meaning at once held it just preserve
traditions at all costs simply because
their traditions and you know if people
a long time ago did something and they
can continue doing it then we should
keep doing that same thing just because
those people did it I think that's also
the wrong approach I mean we should
respect tradition we should take
tradition seriously so that if our
ancestor did the ancestor did have a
tradition we should at least we should
take that seriously we should look at it
and think well there's a reason why they
did this and we shouldn't just toss it
out toss it on the trash heap without
thinking we shouldn't do that but the
royal family now is just you know it's
it's an embarrassment and especially
add this epstein thing into it but it's
not my concern because I'm not British
so as I said we fought a war so that we
didn't have to deal with these people of
course then we came over here and now
we've sort of turned our own political
class into their own form of royalty so
I guess we don't have a lot of room a
lot of room to judge by the way here's a
picture of Prince Andrew and Virginia
Roberts says he never met her but here's
here he is with her now he's got an
explanation for that or a denial anyway
he says that it can't be him
it's not him this must this must be some
kind of trick or sorcery because he says
he would never show that kind of
affection in public and he always wears
a suit and tie so that guy you know that
guy in that picture it's not him it
looks like him that guy is a sweaty slob
that guy is a sweaty dishonorable
disgusting slob which Prince Andrew
definitely isn't he says all right um
before we get the emails let's take a
quick break and well I'm not even gonna
set this up look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
that's that's like the Macarena
but somehow whiter this thing they do
now this is this is a second video we've
seen is the second disturbing footage
we've seen of this I don't want to call
it a dance it's like if the Macarena and
the YMCA dance had a baby and then that
baby grew up and had a baby with the
chicken dance and that's you end up with
this thing that they do and Pete Buju
jizz campaign just if you needed more
reasons not to vote for the guy I think
that's probably all the reason you need
and there are a lot of other good ones
too but we don't even need to get past
that okay we're gonna go to emails now I
did have there's this speaking of
disturbing and creepy there's this
legitimately disturbing and creepy
sprite ad where sprite is trying to
because this is what this is what
companies do now with their
advertisements trying to push delusion
and confusion onto kids and on to the
culture but I think I'm gonna save this
discussion because it deserves a longer
discussion I think not at the very end
of the show so I'm going to save that
for tomorrow we'll talk about that
tomorrow and set we'll go right to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com is the email
this is from Dale says hello Matt love
your show and your witty sarcastic humor
on the current ridiculousness this world
produces helps me last through this
laughs through this craziness and
realize life really isn't that serious
however I'm coming to you for advice on
a very serious matter I want to ask my
girlfriend for her hand in marriage but
I don't know if she feels the same way
that I do she's brought it up before and
mentioned what kind of wedding she wants
but does that mean she's wanting to get
married please help me Dale she's
brought up marriage to you and told you
what
of wedding she wants she wants to get
married yes 100% I so the only thing
that could make it more obvious and
maybe she's already done this but if
she's given you ring sizes when you get
to the to her bring you up her ring size
casually hey by the way just just so you
know my my ring as a size 7 in case you
were wondering
is that how ring sizes work is there a
ring size I forget it's been a while
anyway that's the only thing when she
does that that's the equivalent of you
know one of those banners that the
helicopter flies across the beach when
you're at the beach and there's a big
helicopter advertising a deal at the car
dealership or something that's the
equivalent of that if she put it on it
please propose to me
so she's not quite there but she's
almost there
and so yes get that ring make it happen
cabin and congrats in advance on your
pending nuptials
god bless this is from John Matt when
you move your head a certain way the
globe in the back makes it look like you
have a man bun just thought you should
know
the globe in the back let me see
okay yeah I could see that like I could
see the man actually not a bad look see
there's my man but that's what it would
look like if I had a man bun not too bad
the people hate on the man bun but maybe
maybe it works for some people who would
have thought all right oh you could also
see my back there that's my artwork too
might my daughter did her portrait of me
which I've displayed proudly on my
bookshelf there
she gets her artistic talent not from me
I could tell you that what else here
this is from Druce as mr. Walsh
as a child my mother would give us green
beans and ketchup
I remember the dish fondly and taught it
taught me to eat my greens I
occasionally used ketchup with fries and
somewhat agree with your point the
question is is there an acceptable way
to use ketchup that does not insult the
dish in which it is used
true I hate to be the one to tell you
this but your mother was trying to
poison you call the police it's not too
late ketchup on green beans is an insult
you know if you're going to I don't know
how she prepared the green beans but if
you want to seasoned green beans the
classic salt and pepper will do just
fine you want to throw a little bit of
garlic powder some parmesan on there I'm
not gonna have a problem with that
ketchup there's no place for ketchup on
green peas
there's no place for ketchup period on
any dish because as I said if your
upon your fries it means your fries were
poorly seasoned if you're putting
ketchup on your hamburger it means that
it means that number one the hamburger
was poorly cooked and poorly seasoned
and also apparently you don't have
access to any of the other sauces or
condiments that would be acceptable in
hamburger if you want to go mayonnaise
that's fine you want to go mustard you
want to go you want to go barb any of
the various time cut types of barbecue
sauce there's no reason for ketchup once
you get above the age of about 12 let's
see all my all my emails are basically
about food which I'm not complaining
about this is from Suzanne says hi Matt
I have enjoyed reading your insightful
commentary and wit for several years and
was pleased to hear that you join the
daily our team your podcasts are a
highlight of my weekly listening
experience a while I generally concur
with most your opinions I have on
occasion disagreed such as with your
take on internal household temperatures
but hadn't felt the need to write after
laughing at your incredulity your
concerning chilli and cinnamon rolls
however I thought it important to
educate you on the culinary virtue of
such a combination let me preface with
this I'm a Missouri girl and had never
had chili with anything other than
crackers my husband who hails from
Kansas grew up with chili and cinnamon
rolls served in school back with school
kitchen ladies actually cooked good
homemade food well apparently not
Suzanne if they're serving cinnamon
rolls and chili eventually I learned to
make exceptional cinnamon rolls which I
baked several times a year and always
want to make chili as we say in our
household it's against the law to serve
chili without cinnamon rolls that's
exact I think the truth is the exact
opposite of that actually and we've
converted several guests to this belief
as well they are simply a complementary
combination of savory and sweet like
peanut butter and jelly sea salt and
caramel popcorn and candy the biggest
difference is one bite typically
wouldn't contain both except by those
who are extremely adventurous depending
on preference they can either be eaten
by alternating bites as one would eat a
piece of garlic toast with an Italian
dish or most properly buy popularly by
eating the savory chili as the meal and
finishing with the sweet rolls as
dessert this
as a Hardy cold-weather meal to a
satisfying close and agreed upon by more
than Midwesterners I I don't know what
else to say on this I've already just
I've already communicated my disgust my
moral outrage about chili with cinnamon
rolls and I've gotten so many emails
from people defending this abomination
before God and I also want to make it
clear because a lot of these emails for
making straw men of my position there
been a lot of emails defending cinnamon
rolls in principle I don't have any
issue with cinnamon rolls of course I
enjoy cinnamon rolls
who doesn't I'm an American okay I'm not
a psychopath but I'll have a cinnamon
roll with breakfast okay that's the
proper time where you want to have it as
you know you can have really any time of
day as its own thing if you're if you're
walking through the airport and you pass
by a Cinnabon and you feel like hating
yourself and being depressed and having
a stomachache on the plane then have us
then you know have a Cinnabon go for it
all I'm saying is that the pair with
Chile is is it's it's not just that it's
a bad culinary choice what I am
proposing is that it is ethically and
morally problematic and I think if you
looked in the Bible and I don't have
time to quote it right now but I'm but
I'm pretty sure if you looked in the
Bible you would find that you'd find
some back up on this point finally this
is from well this is okay this is from
Amanda says you have been discussing
strange food pairings and I thought I'd
share mine my grandfather grew up in
Philly and taught us about the wonderful
pairing of peanut butter and mayonnaise
I grew up eating peanut butter
mayonnaise and tomato sandwiches if we
were feeling extra fancy we'd throw some
onions on those suckers YUM
it also eats cinnamon
with our chili as a side but to dunk
Monty
are also something we enjoy here in
Colorado peanut butter mayonnaise tomato
and onion I think I just lost the will
to live I don't even want to this this
descript the description of that dish
makes me long for the cold embrace of
death it makes me think that human
civilization itself was a mistake this
is my God my God have mercy on us
got a mercy on us all as if I needed
more reasons to hate Philadelphia now
I've got another one add it to the list
I was gonna read like five other emails
but I'm too nauseated to continue so we
will end the show there you just ruin
the whole show Amanda I hope your hope
you're proud of yourself and that's it
then Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Democrats in the mainstream media and
Congress all the way to former
presidents throw cold water on the
impeachment push we will examine the
latest bombshell testimony to parse what
if anything this is all about then Kanye
West spreads the gospel to mega church
pastor Joel Osteen Pope Francis wants to
make pollution of sin and a dark-horse
Democratic candidate takes a big lead in
Iowa check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
[Music]